can you imagine it's like a hundred
years from now and there's like little
kids are running to school and they're
wearing their little red you know hats
and there's a statue of donald trump and
it's like donald trump you know hi
and there's a bunch of high schools
across the country across the planet
that are named
trump and they're like 100 years ago
donald trump you know led this country
to great like could you imagine that
historical moment they look back at
trump that way
i think it's going to be very hard to
imagine a building with the word trump
on it
i know that'd be ridiculous the school
the schools are going to have like a
gigantic
golden sign of his name no but i mean
like could you imagine if that's where
we really end up like
for all of his problems he's the he's
actually the guy who gets
the regular people to to you know take
back their liberty
break out of this this uh this numbness
essentially i could see him
leaving office and repurposing his
wealth to do incredible
futuristic technologies and be looked at
no i don't see trump no way
yeah i mean he's got all this money and
now he's got all this you you need to
buck the system
trump is not a technology person trump
would take his money he'd build a
building he's going to he's going to
buck the system by revising the entire
media
that's his buy a news organization
that's a news organization trump isn't
the cause of all this though you know
trump didn't start this
right he's just the avatar of that of
the energy and they don't realize that
they
again i i think we talked about this
last week they thought they killed a
head vampire movie's over
can't figure out how it works well now
they're writing that they've got to go
after trumpism
yeah trump is that was like the day
after the election that that word
but i also think that's them desperate
to keep up their their golden goose
yes like you know they they gutted it
they're like okay well if you know if
trump lost what do we do
what do we write about trump-ism and
there's actually a wikipedia page for
trumpism
like this i kid you not and i'm like
what is it and it's basically it said
ruling by uh by promising people things
and
like offering up division as a means of
excuse what everyone does
it's like it's like it's it's it said
politics basically yeah trumpism
and it's part of a series on
conservatism in the united states
oh boy oh yeah so i don't know man do
you think
uh seeing what's going on in wayne
county this did
i mean well actually we're talking
earlier and it kind of sounded like we
were both in agreement that trump's on
the outs
right yes now how do you feel i still
feel that way but i still think
um he's there did like his percentage go
up a little bit
no i think the percentage of something
black swan went up
like what does that mean meaning
something that neither of us saw funny
uh like some just a weird outline you
know you know like it's it's not i'm
sorry about you it's not impossible that
god forbid something happens to trump or
biden still and then what happens right
right now i don't know what would happen
um
my understanding and i could be wrong is
if biden
something happens to him he's out of the
race the race isn't certified
the election is not certified so if
biden is unable to run
his the votes that went to biden are
they don't go to camp
they don't go they don't go not you vote
for the individual you're not yeah
exactly and so what would happen is then
they would say okay then who got the
most votes donald trump did
could you imagine or each state picks
right and then it could be the
the democrats or it could be someone
else it could be like mike pence
what do you mean like i think the isn't
it my understand that states can vote
whoever they want
uh the state legislators decide how the
electors have to vote that's the supreme
court ruling
my point is i don't think they have to
choose between the top two at that point
yeah you're i think i think you're right
yeah um well actually
most states have a law that says they
have to vote for the person who received
the most votes but if that person is
gone for whatever reason then what
happens it's trump
if if if you're in an election and you
have 10 votes and i have nine and you
can you you drop out of the race
then the person with the most votes is
me you're not in the military but i had
the ten votes
i don't i don't think it works that way
that doesn't make doesn't make sense you
know what i think what would happen very
quickly is that people who
lawyers who think like you had your
argument lawyers think like we have my
argument and then
it's going to be a crisis obviously and
that could seriously happen
about that because true not a shot at a
pressure
could you the guy like he said that he's
going to win dude he said trinidad
pressure i'm getting that feeling of
just giving up where i had about hillary
clinton
no no dude you can't beat the mission i
was thinking
it's going to be joe biden and he's
going to be stan they're not they're
talking about not even having an
inauguration
because of kovid but in reality it's
because privately they're saying this is
reported by politico
i think it's politico they're scared
that it's only going to be trump
supporters who show up right it's going
to be a sea
of people like pulling out he's going to
rule from his base
his basement so he's going to hide but
that would be like seriously my
understanding is that he wants to harken
back to when americans were united and
he's going to be inaugurated using fdr's
wheelchair
before the internet you're joking i'm
joking yeah no i think
um dude i think they're hiding it what
happens if joe biden
puts his hand on the on the on the bible
raises it it starts
smoking yeah then and then his hand
bursts into flames he goes
it wasn't supposed to be a real bible no
but uh
he puts him in the bible and then they
say you know i solemnly swear i solemnly
swear to uphold the constitution of
these uniteds to uphold the
concentration of
these united states and to swirly you
know i don't know actually do you know
what happens then
and then he falls over no it depends it
depends
okay that is an aegis joke michael we
don't allow those in studio
no but i'm like hate agents they're the
worst oh my gosh did you ever see that
video
get it out where there was it was it was
in the uk there was an ad in the
newspaper that said
there were there was a room for rent no
asians
and so this journalist saw it and was
like this is blatantly a violation of
the law it says no asians
so he goes to the guy and the guys he's
like did you say in your ad no asians
and he goes yeah they're terrible people
he's just ragging on him and then he was
like
why why would you say that he goes
because they just want to take your
money and he goes wait what
yeah you got to pay him a fee just to
list your building because he had a
heavy accent no agents
and so they put in the ad asians oh wow
yeah anyway what were we talking about
before
yeah joe biden winning so joe biden's
going to be at the inauguration
and i'm just saying what if this happens
he's reading the oath
and then he keels over likely
what if he can't speak it what if
they're like saying he goes
right conservation so i think in that
case the republicans are going to fight
that he's still the president and the
democrats are going to fight for kabul
harris
so well no if they would go to nancy
pelosi
why because uh if there's no if no one
gets inaugurated on the 20
on the 20th it goes to the next person
in line who is in office
and it's nancy pelosi so the congress
gets their uh
they get sworn in or whatever early
january so if there's no president on
the 20th then nancy pelosi is
duly swift but if he works when's the
vice president sworn in
uh right after the fact i don't know i
don't know i don't know
but that's what everyone's saying if
they don't if they don't uh inaugurate a
new president on the 20th trump is out
and the next person who is in office but
they're not inaugurating the president
and the vice president so if that if joe
biden god forbid kills over that minute
we have a vice president who's
commenting i don't think it would work
that way
i don't think so that that is how if the
president dies he's not sworn in
okay but but it might be because i was
reading something about there's an art a
provision in the constitution saying
that
they would immediately give it to the
vice president-elect yeah so i think it
would immediately go to
homeless but uh but what i was reading
it's like it was
specifically outlining when that happens
and i don't know if it's in that
scenario but there's a scenario where
it's like apparently if there's like a
legal dispute then they
will give it to the vice president-elect
or something no that weird i think that
was the stuff the season finale of veep
what that literally was the season i
don't watch i've never seen
that happen on veep sorry spoil
everything people yeah no i was reading
there's like a second to last season
that's how it ended but that's probably
because it's based on the actual
constitution that's
why it happens no this this stuff is not
in the constitution no they're there
i was reading i was reading a provision
from the constitution that
was explaining when they would bypass
the president-elect for the vice
president-elect it happens
it's i i'm not arguing that that's not
the law i'm saying i don't think that's
in the constitution
that scenario one thing all these things
that you're spelling out are such
complicated um
uh explanations of the law they're not
addressed the constitution is very
very bad about a lot of this stuff
simple yeah
and a lot of these things like the 20
second amendment whatever it was where
they have to be like okay what the
25th amendment like that's them being
like because at first you didn't even
have separate votes for the president
vice president you have the tie
right with uh thomas jefferson aaron
burr in 1800 so it gets good
whoever at the second most became vice
president could you imagine president
biden vice president trump
wow might not be a bad thing i mean i
think i think that was a better system
because then you had competing factions
but
yeah yeah i mean you you'd end up with
competing ideologies but having that you
know level of power
that seems to make more sense they
changed it now you have one party
getting the boot and one party taking
over
also the 17th amendment man that's that
was a terrible idea is that i think
slavery
no the 17th was uh appointing senators
by popular vote oh of course that's a
terrible idea it used to because what it
did
in my opinion i was reading about it is
that it's took away
states like state political activity
essentially right people used to
actually care about who they would vote
for for their state legislature now they
don't know or care
and it was supposed to be that the state
representatives would vote
for a senator to go and represent the
state to the federal government
makes a lot of sense they passed the
17th for a bunch of reasons
and uh one of which was like uh elites
were paying for senatorships and stuff
like that
because it was really easy to bribe ten
people to like get you the vote or even
you know six to get the majority
and so they're like we'll do it by
popular vote and that basically
then i'll put it this way you know
what's really funny is when people are
like
you see these commercials and it'll be a
congressman or a senator or a
congresswoman or whatever and they're
like i'm gonna clean up
our district it's like you're a federal
representative
you don't clean up our district you
represent us to the federal government
it's our local politicians who are going
to clean up our streets why are you
campaigning as if you're going to do
something here
they don't what here's a complete
non-sequitur but that's okay
that kim girl from baltimore did she win
did she do well no not when
yeah she'd come classic yeah who did
better her laura loomer
uh i think percentage ones i think laura
may have okay oh so she got
kim got completely cleaned i mean she i
don't know the the actual results
okay but but i'm pretty sure they're
both in like very heavily democratic
yeah yeah yeah surprisingly laura lumer
did really well
yeah okay i'm but i'm not entirely
surprised i mean trump was there trump
probably voted for her he did vote for
her yeah i mean he's not gonna vote for
the democrats of course yeah so
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you